he's a criminal good
alright guys I just went through a very
lengthy explanation as to like this
Suicide Squad is because she does she's
not familiar with the DC but this video
has nothing to do with DC it's just
happens to be called 5 real-life suicide
squads so Elise is perfect for this
lengthy I'm not trying to make you look
that I'm just saying it was a long
discussion the breath is out of it dark
five great channels subscribe to them
dark fives a great channel if you like
dark information in the top I form a
pitch unit six I wish I was part of a
Suicide Squad no you don't understand
ish instead in the south korean
president in central such as foreign
forms black ops unit of thirty one petty
criminals at the point you've given one
goal to eliminate north korean premier
Wow
thirty one petty criminals not criminal
recruitment was to give the mission
possibility deniability
that's so cool
it's like criminals and train them in
most of the regards and escape me from
the fun in heaven o dicks they fought
against them and escaped all before were
killed in a firefight with an army after
hijacking it buses soul and the
survivors were executed after trial ah
you [ __ ] I was about to be a really
cool story
South Korean kept the incidents eager
until in 1990s and a motive for the
uprising was never uncovered oh wow wow
any lane
[Music]
named after a Beatles song penny is a
nickname of a hidden cluster of cottages
in Guantanamo Bay that's where Harold
and Kumar went in the second movie deals
their former bit where prisoners were
trained by the CIA to kill terrorists in
exchange for freedom and millions in
cash Wow Wow
President Bush's Phyllida have had taken
a personal interest in the group and a
bomb a use of double agents for drone
strikes
Wow sweet us egg sea air poorly even
consider releasing prisoners into the US
on false visas and hope that they would
connect with sleeper cells
there was an irony in letting the very
worst go while other prisoners remain
jailed without evidence still though man
snoods criminal make the Michael Jackson
song wow they're really look smooth
criminal were to my journals bill Dean
describes a secret US intelligence
bought and endorsed by JFK and JFK did
was cool yeah in which America's most
hardened criminals were released to
fight communism the any risk of
implicating the US government how do you
fight
like they would just go to war according
to the author sources say whoa rapists
drug dealers mafia hitmen Wow Wow
that's like a real Suicide Squad deep
finally one man American current wave
sent to Cuba to poison Castro whoa did
you succeed I don't know what happened
Reilly was a lot to embezzle commit
fraud run two guns and deal drugs
without being arrested Wow all to catch
a bigger fish a bigger fish
death work jihad
Topsy gonna tell us now from Saudi
Arabia's about how their government
parted a thousand death row and it's
okay thousand death blossom sorry
they're from death by sorting exchange
for joining satyr despite to topple
Syria's not shower out very familiar
with all that I'm not at all it is
believed that the special soldier
program may have been overseen am i
overseen I've been overseen by overseen
by a Saudi prince with genocide all the
time no no according their I can't be a
Russia pressure the king of the
abandoned prisoner program I threatened
to report it to the UN now finding in
the Syrian civil war has continued in
both countries are still believed
meddling in the common yeah
Wow there really like tried something
different there huh
here we go number one 1:36 Waffen us if
it's loosely heinous units in the Nazi
German war machine of three six bluffing
for me Wow
what they did that was so right a unit
first comprised by of poachers and later
by capital offenders deserters
concentration camp inmates and the
criminally insane
that's a [ __ ] team right there the
herbalist commanded by an austere derlo
winder mentally insane well convicted
rapists with a reputation SS she's not
from her taking the horrific acts
classically burning civilians a live
feed him dogs
[Music]
the universe is expected to die on the
front line yet agree to the size of a
gay that killed hundreds of thousands
whoa
hello dark five hey he's just a friendly
faceless narrator so hang on Suicide
Squad you ever wonder what makes
characters like the Joker tick what's
the hidden meaning behind the madness
head over wise so I can watch this video
on the philosophy of the Joker to find
out do we take him to wisecracks channel
page where you can subscribe and tell
them the dark five section
[Music]
Wow um that was great the video wow man
I watched something like that before I
bet all these are true yeah bet they're
all true I would love to see a movie
based off all of them I love those
movies that are like like the movie
Valkyrie where I was like the secret
group that was sending to kill Hitler
the Korean Won is South Korean one that
one kind of disappointed me because it
said they got 31 criminals together
mm-hmm
one giving goal yeah I mean this is like
they had any reward though so they
repelled a mutiny and they killed Hey
a lot of [ __ ] people and eventually
they all died and even the ones are a
coward chill after trial so nothing
really so yeah I mean like the group was
assembled I get what this was the first
one they show us that right man I bet if
they offered them some reward like I
don't know yeah what kind of reward
western bagels unlimited I hear Korea
was her bagel is a popular franchise
okay well everywhere you go they say a
Korean has a bagel in the sand I'm gonna
ask my ask you're an chosen career right
she's Korean
that's the risk though that you run of
putting together one of these groups yes
you're not dealing with people who are
mentally stable or so you're likely that
they might rebel on go against you you
know like don't [ __ ] it like a soldier
there's something like sick [ __ ]
people like psychotic people yeah I
would want on MoBay CIA they train
people who train prisoners right kill
terrorists or sings for freedom and
millions in cash what they talked about
too because again prisoners are bad
already
what are sleeper cells are we Google Inc
a secretive group of spies or terrorist
agents that remain intact of
target population and so order to act
ooh that's kind of cool looking at this
as a movie in ever real life just be
ready for when we call on you you live
your life but be ready you'll get a call
when I'm call
yeah you're on call any could be years
from now there's gonna be a time where
you're on call yeah I mean it's not cool
you're on call hey we need some bad guys
I watched an episode of flash where he
had to work with Captain Cold
mm-hmm who has a freeze gun Shh and a
sister with a cold gun he needed their
help and you know what they ended up a
trained him it didn't pan out in the end
I can't trust these bad guys there's a
reason why they're bad well smooth
criminal sounded cool
the CIA said loose rapists drug dealers
and mafia oh my god that's like didn't
you say that was like the the legit
Suicide Squad yeah that's like those are
bad those are people not like oh we rob
banks and do crazy shouldn't be killed
like these are guys who like these are
just like not good human NASA people who
need to be like kept somewhere stay in
prison but the fact is love them like
run loosely you do ever you want we
still get your help like that's terrible
hey man hey sometimes you just got it
the word the US and we gotta do we gotta
do sometimes they listen and accept well
obviously not in all of these but I know
my manager of this apartment Rob's me
all right the amount you're putting this
out there no I paid this stuff and it's
ridiculous the bills sometimes and like
the lack of informing us when they're
gonna turn off the water oh it's it's
very frustrating here's what I can tell
you okay I know the reason she's not
getting fired is because the government
or something only reason I can
understand is why she wanted yes yeah
she watches if you're watching this I
[ __ ] get the message everyone thinks
it about you yeah Oregon something right
now god this guy austere face gives JLo
Wanger methylenes to anger his face just
Springs about a lot of creeps I know I
know
feels I feel like we know someone in
class you could play him hey care to
share
Terry target Tariq yeah he's my current
scene partner I love you Tariq I really
think you could play this guy like or
Chris Barry yeah maybe you guys to help
promote even we're saying this because
you're talented well I mean I hear the
description here
I don't really know these guys outside
class wonderful I just think we need a
Suicide Squad in acting like we need
some real like [ __ ] up human beings to
portray [ __ ] up human beings are
acting that though how many like you
have to get in so many like worlds for
that yeah as an actor I go there you
have to be a lot of emotions and
memories maybe you could play him I
can't I don't have the looks too good
looking you know I can't transform this
too much of the point where I'm oh well
I'm just saying you have to be very deep
and dark and I don't know you have to
get in order to play something like this
you just have to really I don't even
know
he kind of looks like some of my
relatives oh my god really
yeah I mean this guy to actually do
these horrible [ __ ] things to see
these people it's the Nazis were like
something else man like the [ __ ] they
did like crazy [ __ ] stories and I've
seen some movies that portrayed some
horrible things some documentaries on
that face I wish I was one of the
inglorious bastards you ever see that I
haven't seen that yeah that's about
glorious bastards are deist team of I
think they're all Jews but they're
Jewish soldiers and they get together
with lieutenant aldo raine and their
goal kill as many [ __ ] Nazis as
possible oh my god
scalp them scalp them yeah sorry Brad
Pitt directed by Quentin Tarantino and
written by him Wow Academy Award winning
performance by Christoph Waltz if you
guys are new to the channel subscribe
today oh man I'm gonna battery's gonna
die okay yeah it's gonna die Lisa it's
gonna die I will lose all the footage
you are certain in life in this battery
is going to die
Lisa mihalick is on Instagram great
profile there but keep a lookout for her
movies and TV that's where she's coming
at you thank you we're Greg and Lisa
dark five subscribe to them